[Musique]
j'estime qu'entre deux êtres humains ya
des tas de sentiments amicaux et qui
peuvent exister on peut trouver des tas
d'affinités ensemble
qui peut créer un lien
nobles sentiments
pourquoi n'existe-t-il pas à nommer une
femme entre un homme une femme il peut
pour avoir d'amitié avec de l'amour et
encore si on peut appeler ça comme ça
c'est une question d'habitude c'est
possible ça m'est arrivé
oui bien sûr j'ai eu froid c'est
c'est des choses qui discutent pas ça on
sait comme ça et ça va tout seul
trois ans tout est possible entre un
homme et une femme pourquoi pas d'amitié
tout à fait normal
bien sûr
parce que c'est normal ça normal passé
comme ça c'est difficile la métier entre
filles et garçons
mais si c'est une personne qui a les
mêmes activités que vous c'est très
possible quoi
bon
bah oui j'y crois
parce que chez les deux sexes opposés
levé ce que c'est il ya deux sexes
différents ils sont créés pour l'amour
je crois plutôt à l'amour mais enfin
pourquoi pas l'amitié oui ça doit
exister
j'y crois mais ça peut durer quelques
temps mais à la fin je crois que ça
passe un peu à l'amour oui certainement
certainement parce que j'ai une certaine
bonne question d'entente
d'abord une question de compréhension et
de bonne volonté je ne comprends pas je
crois que l'amour ça commence d'abord
par d'amitié
oui
c'est est ce que j'ai la ville
je crois que c'est
quand même raison
à notre époque je pense que c'est
possible parce que plus en plus la femme
sera libéré de ses tabous il est
faisable qu' un homme et une femme
puisse rêver d'amitié mais plus souvent
quand même d'amour
je
oui je suis un certain moment mais
après c
je crois c'est pas possible oui je crois
à l'amitié entre une femme et un homme
une très bonne amitié c'est peut-être
parce que je suis âgée se peut très bien
mais même jeune j'y ai toujours cru
je vois l'amitié aussi avec un homme une
femme a entre la nommer une femme parce
que faut pas s'imaginer qu'il ya que des
choses vilaine entre un homme et une
femme
on peut avoir une amitié sur scène non
pas tellement la femme est jolie ça ne
peut pas durer très longtemps en tant qu
amitié ou alors c'est très surfait de la
part de l'homme
[Musique]